on the weekend
coming up on c-span 3 history the topic
is america's revolutionary war first
it's a people's history of the
revolution followed by the c-span school
bus touring sites related to the war of
independence
then at 12 o'clock historian walter
edgart discusses his book partisans and
redcoats you're watching c-span 3
history
now a discussion about the influence of
common people in the american revolution
this event's about an hour and a half
our dean jerry murphy i'm very happy to
welcome you here tonight
i'd also welcome you to pick up a flyer
of the upcoming events that we have here
we will be finishing our forum season
here
on may 15th but next week we have gene
trownstein who is speaking about her new
book shakespeare behind bars
and showing excerpts
film excerpts from her prison students
performance of merchant of venice
and on thursday of that week we have
robert taurus a
gay puerto rican educator who was the
narrator and subject of a
really amazing film
called new york and dream
and we will be showing that movie and
discussing the film with robert torres
afterwards
and on may 7th mary mazzio carol
gilligan and mary jo kane who's the
university of minnesota as director of
the tucker center for research on girls
and women in sports
we'll be here to show and talk about the
title ix film called the hero for daisy
which is about the tenacious 1976
yale women's rowing team
and franz dewall a primatologist from
emory university we'll be here to talk
about
the ape and the sushi master that has to
be an all-time great title
on may 9th and we end our forum season
with ray kurzweil
the inventor
extraordinary and techy guy
and author of the age of the spiritual
machine who's going to be in
conversation with howard gardner
the multiple intelligences guru and the
two of them will be speaking about
intelligence
computer and human
so we would welcome you to any or all of
those and
but of course for tonight
we're here to listen to and experience
and for those of you who know howard you
know the
informed word is experience both howard
zinn and ray raphael
it's actually quite wonderful to have
them here this week
both howard and ray are known for their
social consciousness and their social
activism
relic terms often associated with the
60s and the 70s
but this week harvard yard has been the
site of an extraordinary burst of social
activism as harvard students have taken
over memorial hall to protest the
failure of the university to pay some of
its employees a living wage
i hope you'll indulge me as i quote from
an open letter to the community
from over a dozen house masters as as it
appeared in the crimson yesterday
we as house masters recognize that the
issue of a living wage affects the
quality of our community life in the
harvard houses
in the houses the living wage issue has
a human face
the living wage campaign invites us to
ask if we are doing as much as we can to
ensure that the workers in our
communities are receiving adequate
compensation for their work and their
contributions to our daily lives
we appreciate the care and diligence of
our students in bringing this issue of
wages to the attention of the entire
harvard community in their work and
written reports over the past two years
we have deep respect for their
commitment to social and economic
justice and we support them in their
commitments and it has really been quite
extraordinary to see how the harvard
community
has
really rallied solidly behind this issue
we could never in our wildest dreams
have contrived such a meaningful welcome
for howard and ray
uh two men committed to writing and
teaching about history from the point of
view of those who are often
most neglected and ignored howard and
ray exercised what they call a bottom-up
approach to examining new and critical
perspectives on the american past
and in doing so they've created
histories which resonate with all of us
their histories tell stories
and through engaging us in the struggles
of ordinary people they give us
connection
understanding and insight
to times and events which previously
seemed lifeless and irrelevant
people of all colors from every class
and economic level walk through their
books
and in doing so help us to understand
not the extraordinary but the ordinary
events which cumulatively
make up the fabric of this country
howard zinn is the series editor and
inspiration for the new press's people's
history
he is a professor emeritus at boston
university
despite john silber's best wishes
and author of the people's history of
the united states
the award-winning declarations of
independence
failure to quit as well as a recent
memoir entitled
and another excellent title you can't be
neutral on a moving train
he is also the author of the play marks
in soho
ray raphael grew up in new york city
received his ba from reed college in his
m.a from berkeley he then left academia
to work in the peace and civil rights
movements of the sixties
before becoming part of the back to the
land movement of the seventies
moving to the backwards backwoods of
northern california removed from
electricity telephone and pavement
while living there he taught in a
one-room public high school teaching
history math english forestry and
physical education
he's a prolific writer his works include
an everyday history of somewhere
the teacher's voice
the men from the boys rights of passage
in male america
and now a people's history of the
american revolution
tonight we'll begin with howard zinn
then move to ray raphael and we will
finally give you all a chance to ask
your own questions so thank you for
coming howard
[Applause]
thank you daddy engler
for for organizing this i think you
organize this you're the one who always
calls me
so
uh very happy to be here with ray rafael
we actually
yeah
we've done a couple of things before we
just said something in new york and we
did something we were together in
california
it's becoming a thing
and
i'm very glad daddy has started off
talking about
what's going on
uh here the the students sitting in
for a living wage because
you're right that's a
if we're writing a history of harvard
university
we might leave them out unless we were
doing a people's history of harvard
university and we're doing a people's
history of howard university and then we
would have them then we'd have the
anti-war protesters of the 60s and then
we'd have the members of the john reed
club we'd have all the people who were
turned over to the fbi by harvard
university
uh now maybe i'm exaggerating but
uh
well this you know there's some
connection between harvard university
and
the establishment
isn't there
i think so no
but
no no of course not
but
um
i i suppose i contrast
this is the the sit in
as you know people's history and i
contrast that with
the other harvard
uh and the other harvard is epitomized
for me
by
walking into weidner library
and unless they have now removed it but
i doubt it but then when you go up the
stairs of widener library you see this
tribute to a soldier and tribute to a
soldier is good
except that
there's a slogan that accompanies this
tribute to a soldier there are different
ways you can pay tribute to a soldier
and there's a way
you pay tribute to a soldier which
uh is unsettling and and
this tribute
at harvard it says
happy is he
who with one
embrace
clasps death and victory
am i right
do you remember that
yeah
i didn't like that you say
uh
and every time i went into widener
yeah
that i was reminded of that so anyway
it's good these
people who are sitting are reminding us
of the invisible people and that's the
idea of a people's history you know
that's what rey
is doing in his people's history of the
american revolution i'm not the
co-author of that book so you're right
some some people think you know because
my name appears i have to make sure even
though i want to be a co-author of every
good book but i'm not the co-author of
that book but the new press which is
doing this series you know said to me
will you be general editor of the syria
people's history series and i thought i
don't want to be general editor of
anything
and then they
uh because i think of general editors
being one of these
academic entrepreneurs you know no
but then they sent me rey's book
and i read it and i thought wow
this is i've read a fair amount on the
american revolution
this is the best single book on the
american revolution that i've read
so
happy to do this
so yes
the
uh
and it's there's a connection between
the history of in invisible people
in the past
and the story of invisible people in the
presence as the connection between you
know the invisible people of the
american revolution and its time and the
invisible people out in our time
and it seems to me you can you can go
from one to the other that is
by looking into by looking at the
present and being conscious of the
people we don't notice in the present
you can then be induced to look into the
past and say hey what are the what are
the counterparts of these people i know
about today the cleaning people and the
and the
immigrants and the hard-working people
who overlooked what is that counterpart
in the past and that leads you to
people's history of the past that lead
you to look for different things in the
past than the kind of things you get in
traditional textbooks or you can go the
other way you can go into history and
and read read a
book like raise or read other books that
will tell you about native americans and
women and black people and working
people and african americans and then
ask yourself what is their counterpart
today
but in either way a connection is made
between the past and the present
and it's important to know that because
there's no point going into the past if
you're never going to come out of it
there's no point going to the past
unless you're going to make a connection
between what you learn about the past
and what you see no in the present
i must tell you
let's see how i came to
this sounds very dramatic
how i came
to my present point of wisdom
i must tell you how i how i came to
think of you know doing people's history
[Music]
i was in the south i was living in the
south i was teaching at spelman college
in atlanta georgia
uh in black women's college became
involved in the movement
and then began became involved with snik
the student on violent coordinating
committee began moving around the south
becoming a kind of writer participant in
the movement went to albany georgia and
selma alabama and wherever snyk was
doing things wherever the movement was
engaged and going into towns in
mississippi and jackson and greenwood
and greenville and hattiesburg and so on
and
uh
it occurred to me the things i was
seeing
i know we're not being recorded anywhere
they're not becoming part of anyone's
history oh well sure i was reading in
the papers about what the heads of the
naacp were saying and what the latest
legal struggles were you know on the
level of courts and you know and what
possible legislation that might be in
congress and what the president might be
saying but the things that i was seeing
on the ground level were not becoming
part of history and so i i wrote a
letter
to
columbia university
my alma mater
although i don't have
a maternal or paternal relationship
you know but you know it's
let's put it this way i went to columbia
university and i that's where i got my
doctorate that's why i did my graduate
work and i knew they had an oral history
project which was new at that time now
oral history is known that time oral
history was new there was no stud turkle
around that well he was around but he
wasn't doing those things and
oral history project and i had fact done
some work in the columbia university
oral history project
and i knew what the oral history project
consisted of sister of somebody
interviewing
ex-secretaries of state
ex-generals
admirals x almost everybody who was
important in the higher echelons of
government and industry you know and you
know trying to catch them before they
died
and that's the trick of oral history
you know
you know you
follow the health reports
and you interview people who are about
to go and you get them at the right
moment because i knew that's what the
oral history project consisted of and so
i wrote to columbia university i wrote
to the oral history project and i said
hey
well i didn't start off that way because
you don't write that way to columbia
university but i said
there's terrific oral history to be done
down here
i mean
come to send somebody down here with
tape recorders
take the people in albany georgia who's
been demonstrating i mean who knows
what's happening in albany georgia tape
these people who've just come out of
jail in albany georgia a good part of
the black population in albany georgia
has been in jail talk to them go to
selma alabama take the selma freedom
chorus and a church rally that takes
place before people are going out to try
to register to vote in some you know go
to greenwood mississippi talk to mrs
ruby pilcher who
lives next door to the freedom house set
up by the snick workers and who brings
them food and takes care of them and
talk to her about her life and and
you know that's oral history
i got this letter back from columbia
university
that's a wonderful idea when somebody
starts off that way you get very
suspicious
a wonderful idea you know it's like
gandhi said about western civilization a
great idea
you know
uh
one yeah
but
we don't have the resources
we don't have the resources i don't know
the university doesn't have the
resources to do that it's like harvard
university doesn't have the resources to
pay a living wage to its workers right
none of these people you know it's like
you know really it's like the
it's always that way i mean the people
with the most resources don't have the
resources you know the united the
richest country in the world doesn't
have the resources to take care of the
health needs of 40 million people you
know that's that's that's the story on
every possible low they don't have the
resources but what it really means is
they don't have the interest
it means they don't care
that's what it really means
it means that
they don't need these people they don't
need to represent these invisible people
because
we're represented
we're represented by the secretary of
state you know we're represented by the
people up on high they're they're the
ones who take care of things
and so you know
we don't we don't need these voices uh
that's the idea
and the premise of this is
that uh
this is one big family this country
and uh we all have a common interest
so that
therefore the people
who are on top they can represent
everybody
uh we are divided by class and race and
sex and this and that no it's as the
constitution begins a preamble of the
constitution because we the people of
the united states
right that's all of us got together in
philadelphia those 55 rich white men who
got together in philadelphia this
wonderful multicultural group got
together
in philadelphia and
we the people of the united states
you know no so they yeah they think yeah
we're all one and therefore we can be
represented by the people with money and
power
and so that in fact we have the language
to to uh exemplify that we have you know
the national interest
shall we do this should we go here
should we send troops there should we
bomb here well if it's in the national
interest
and who's interest
there's no national there's no
single entity there's no
what
could could venegat spoke
a grand falloon some of you may remember
a grand faloon is this sort of
something which is sort of
encompasses everything pretends to
encompass everything you see but it
really it can't you know it's a great
big bubble
you see and which is artificial which
needs to be punctured
by the truth in order to reveal the
complexities inside in order to reveal
the different interests that are inside
this bubble are different interests in
america
and so there's no such thing as the
national interest national defense
national security
or is it somebody's securities
that's you know closer to it
but
but that's the that's the pretense you
know that we have this this all this
common interest and no recognition of
the fact that we are
a class
society uh have always been
and well you'll read about the
revolutionary period and i mean that's
one of the things that that ray brings
out in this book but but uh i mean this
is true all through american
history you can
you could write a history of the united
states the overview history of the
united states and start off with a
sentence the history of the united
states is a history of class struggle
well that would be a dangerous way to
start off it would be hard to get a
publisher
a mainstream certainly a mainstream
publisher to to do a history tonight but
the truth is that yes
we were society riven by class right
from the very beginning riven by race
driven by right from the beginning it's
not that you know we were all pilgrims
you know coming here dressed in those
funny costumes sharing everything
writing the mayflower con i remember all
that stuff
given no no
there was us and there were the native
americans there were there were blacks
and and slaves and there were the slave
holders they were the servants or the
masters there were people given huge
grants of land you know huge huge grants
of land other people no land at all
property-less people from the beginning
and and up all through american history
you know i mean james madison recognized
this
when he was writing in the federalist
papers and he's trying to persuade
people to ratify the constitution he
said well we need a government we need a
strong government why do we need a
strong government because
well there there's conflict
we their society is divided into
factions federalist number 10 right
society is divided into factions
uh based on what some people have
property some people don't have property
there's going to be conflict we've got
to do something about controlling this
conflict
we have this nice new strong government
uh it will help to control this conflict
he was very aware as were all the
founding fathers as all those people who
gathered together
very conscious of the rebellions that
had just taken place after the
revolution uh just shay's rebellion
being the most recent one just before
and there's a there's an important
uh conjunction between the shea's
rebellion of 1786 and
and the
framing of the constitution in 1787
because the framers of the constitution
were very conscious of the fact that out
in western massachusetts thousands of
farmers had gathered and rebelled
against the elite of boston against the
high taxes that they had to pay and they
had surrounded courthouses and they had
prevented the court proceedings from
going on this was a real rebellion and
there were similar rebellions in other
parts of the country in virginia and
pennsylvania
in new jersey similar rebellion and now
the founding fathers were conscious of
this and one of them
one of the washington's generals general
knox
uh
wrote to him after shae's rebellion said
hey
i always think these guys start off that
way but no
they
they no they very elegant writers those
and but in effect
in effect he said
uh
he said these people
uh in chase are better many of them
veterans you know veterans of the
revolutionary war captain daniel shays
himself a veteran many of these people
veterans the revolution where they come
back and they find that all those
promises oh how universal a story this
is of veterans being given promises that
if they fight and sacrifice that they
will come back and there'll be a new
world and so on and uh and and knox
writes to washington so these people
fought in the rev they think because
they fought in the revolution
that uh now
the fruits
the wealth of this country
belongs equally to them
well this is dangerous
and so a government is set up which is
going to try to control
rebellion i mean that's that was the the
idea of the concept the idea of the
constitution was not as even
some you know very
prominent historians that oh they wanted
these are very wise they were smart men
eloquent men but the the myth is that
their idea was to set up a democratic
society and you know liberty and justice
and no that was not the intent was to
set up a government that would be able
to control things
be able to deal with indians uh
as the settlers moved out west be able
to deal with a slave rebellions to be
able to deal with working people who
were built that was the idea of it so
well that and so in fact the government
was set up that was able to deal with
that and has been able to deal with that
ever since because ever since then we've
had uh government and legislation that
was represented a particular class of
americans that didn't represent the poor
and didn't represent the black and
didn't represent the immigrants and
didn't represent the native americans
the history of legislation in this
country from that point to this point
has been a history of legislation to
benefit a very small group of people
been a few departures from that when
went at a time when there were great
social movements that that forced you
might say pressured for departures from
that in 1930s in the new deal in the
1960s with those movements and so on but
by and large you know that has been a
story and a history a society
divided by by class and race and and so
on
and uh so
it's
i'm looking at the clock
because you know we have a deal
i'm a very disciplined person
uh
listen to orders
and
the people who run these things are very
tough
don't be deceived by their appearance
you know uh
but um
but the uh
and so the history when you have a
society divided this way
history is going to reflect
those conflicts and those divisions it's
it's uh it can't be a neutral history a
history of which oh the history
represents everybody history is going to
be written from a point of view
and some people are going to be left out
and some people are going to be given
prominent uh attention
uh
and
uh and so you well it's it's when you
think about when you think about doing
history or writing
presenting history it's inevitable right
that that you have an enormous mass of
data
and inevitably you must choose from that
enormous mass of data what you're going
to present in in in when you write
history when you teach history and you
choose according to what you think is
important that is you choose according
to your point of view and depending on
where you are and where you sit and or
who you're trying to please uh you will
have a different notion you know of what
you know is important
uh and so uh
but if you look at it from the point of
view of people who have been generally
left out
of the dominant landscape of american
history uh things look different you
know the american revolution looks
different from the point of view of
indians
the jacksonian period i remember was
taught to us as
jacksonian democracy those
those words always went together
jacksonian democracy jackson was a slave
holder jackson was a racist jackson was
an indian killer and in the period of
jacksonian democracy the uh
the industries were beginning in new
england and girls were going to work at
the age of 12 and dying at the age of 25
and and you know in this period of
jacksonian democracy and also this is a
period in which the
the
army of the united states under with
jackson's orders were driving the
indians of the south east out of their
homes across the mississippi the trail
of tears four thousand out of sixteen
thousand die in the trail of tears this
was that's only a democracy so looking
at jacksonian democracy from different
points of view
you have to
separate those two words uh you look at
the uh
look at a civil war from the standpoint
of of indians
the civil war is a war for the
liberation of slaves
yes and in fact you know there's a kind
of emancipation that takes place uh as a
result of the civil war and yet during
the civil war
while armies were fighting the
confederates in various parts of the
country
uh
other parts of the army were out west
annihilating indian tribes
more land was taken away from indians
during the years of the civil war than
in any comparable period in american
history
so yes if you look at the civil war from
a different point of view you know yet
become something else the industrial
revolution the great economic miracle of
the united states
uh
and i remember sitting there in class
and marveling at
wow
that's when we became a great economic
power and we're taught to take we're
taught to take pride in
you know
the wealth of carnegie
or the achievements of the great you
know and then
how many steel ingots were produced
you know and how many miles of railroad
track were laid and you know it's all us
it's all us
our interests are the same you see and
uh but from the point of view of the
people who worked in rockefeller's
oil refineries the people who worked in
the chinese and irish immigrants who
worked on the transcontinental railroad
you know from a standpoint that people
worked in carnegie's steel mills no it
wasn't simply uh a great economic
miracle you know and
it was a human cost to economic progress
which is not much dealt with in the
traditional histories of you know
that that great period of industrial
expansion between the civil war and
world war one
uh
so uh yes at different different points
of view depending on uh
well take the progressive so-called
progressive era in american history i
say so-called it wasn't so-called okay
uh
uh
progressive ear why some reforms were
passed
roseville was present
uh progressive era is exactly that
period in which more black people were
lynched in this country than any other
period you know
roosevelt the great progressive
roosevelt you know there he is on mount
rushmore
a warmonger a militarist a lover of war
a man who who
observes a massacre taking place in the
philippines
while he's president and congratulates
the the military general who orders the
massacre of 600 uh philippine men women
and children and but you know our heroes
when you look at it depending on your
point of view the heroes are different
you know it's no longer theodore
roosevelt it's it's uh it's emma goldman
and mother jones you know and helen
keller and eugene debs
you know and frederick douglass and w.b
du bois you know you just get different
heroes depending on your point of view
and uh
i
uh
i have a few more minutes
i i just want to assure the people who
are threatening me
that i have a few more nights
you see and uh
but i guess
the the
one thing i want to say
ignore all the other things i was saying
oh well preface that's all
the one thing i want to say
is that this this approach to history
uh this presenting of history from the
standpoint of what do our leaders do you
know uh what is congress you know
telling the story of america from the
standpoint of what are the statutes
passed by congress and what are
decisions made by this supreme court and
what are the edicts you know
by the presidents and so on and and uh
and who are the military heroes that we
should direct statute to
this approach is a profoundly
undemocratic one and we're presumably a
democratic country but that's a
profoundly undemocratic approach to
history the leaving out of the point of
view of uh
people who who are yes invisible who
don't have power
and
and what it does
that kind of history it creates a
passive citizenry
it creates a citizenry that believes
that the important things that are done
are done by important people and that
all that is left for us to do all that's
left for citizens to do is to engage in
the most puny act of citizenship and
that is to vote
really because all we have to do is vote
for these you know we have a choice what
a choice we always have
but to vote that's our that's our
that's the pinnacle of citizenship in
this supposedly democratic country to
vote for a or b or a or a prime you see
and
but in fact the history of the country
shows that when important gains were
made in injustice in economic justice or
racial justice
or the
attention paid to the problems of women
in the existence of women when when
whenever
progress was made it was not made
through the initiative of people on top
was made by citizens by people uh
getting together by organizing by the
labor organizing by anti-war people
organizing by women organizing by
disabled people organizing by gay and
lesbian people or
that's when that's when things change
it's important to know that so that you
don't remain a passive citizen
uh and so you you understand that we all
will have a role to play it seems to me
that that is the importance of of
people's history and that's why i'm so
glad that
ray raphael has done his book and now
he's going to talk to you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
so howard said that the people who give
the orders uh around here and of course
he was the one to receive them so
he told me he says when i introduce you
i want to come i want you to come okay
so
he can he can give a few orders too
all right
i'm going to talk tonight about
writing common people into history
why we do it what we can learn from it
uh why it's so seldom done what are some
of the obstacles we face
the obstacles let me give you an example
of the obstacles we face i moved out to
california in the 1960s
and i met many people from the 1960s
california style a lot of these people
believed in past lives
and the ones who believed in past lives
it's phenomenal how many people during
the middle ages had been princes and
princesses
very few peasants in those times
it was a reverse kind of social pyramid
so this is what we face uh this is what
we're up against this actually goes
quite profoundly deep in our society
in our consciousness
um would uh common people that's my
focus first let me define that common
people
um you have to watch out with people the
term people because it's really that
that term can really be mustered from
the left or the right or even the center
in its behalf the center i'm referring
to the will of the american people
uttered by ultra privileged male
politicians in this last election
a little too often for my liking
so i'm going to define common people
very simple definition
as those who do not enjoy the special
privileges of wealth prestige or
political power
or alternately if you prefer
uh all those whom alexander hamilton
warned us against
so um
why do we study common people okay this
uh there's really several levels of it
first on the most basic level it's a
question of just simple social justice
giving equal air time give credit where
credit's due beyond that what's really
more important is
it's through history that we learn how
to interpret the political process
through the study of history for years
in school fourth fifth seventh eighth
grade so on until you're about a senior
you learn history before you learn how
our present political process is
supposed to work and in history then if
you study the workings of the from
basically top-down history of the elite
that's the way you just come to imagine
that's what politics is that's the way
history work politics works since it
worked then we can marginalize people in
the past therefore we can marginalize
people in the present so there's a whole
political message there
and beyond that from the historian's
point of view you want to study common
people just for the sake of accuracy you
leave out too much when you don't
imagine a history of the depression that
basically is a study of fdr
now this is you know the comparable if
you go back to the revolution we have
those things we have histories of the
revolution which are basically a study
not of fdr but of his counterparts and
they call that a history of the
revolution
well uh it leaves out too much let me
give you an idea of some of the things
that it leaves out that i cover in my
book
in well
what i do in my book i take my lens my
focusing lens and i switch from george
washington over here about 90 degrees
and come over to his slaves his uh the
indians whom he displaced the soldiers
whom he commanded in the army their
wives their mothers
the the women who followed the army all
these other people
so let's look at some of these other
people the slaves about one in every
five slaves in the south
ran to the british for their freedom
during the revolutionary war
this included
17 of washington's own slaves 30 of
jefferson's own slaves
and this was really an exodus of
biblical proportions really greater than
the more famous underground railroad
that followed
so huge consequences here
uh it was i guess howard and i have an
argument as to whether the civil war or
the revolutionary war was the largest
indian war in our nation's history uh
but uh it's certainly it's uh what we
you think of indian wars as you know
okay the white's going out and after the
indians
and it's much more complex than that in
the revolutionary war every single
native american east of the mississippi
was directly affected by the
revolutionary war most of them cited one
way or the other uh and most of them
sided with the losing side namely the
british this opened up all the lands
and uh and they suffered the
consequences uh it was really the the
largest war indian war in the nation's
history
the um
even the very beginning of the war
most people everybody really agrees that
the beginning of the american revolution
started in lexington and concord shot
heard around the world paul revere and
all that
that's april 19 1775.
the previous summer 1774
there were in every county seat
throughout rural massachusetts thousands
upon thousands of farmers went to the
courthouses dragged out every british
appointed official deposed them dragged
them out into the streets or onto the
commons where they have to run the
gauntlet
they made them take off their hats and
recite their resignations between maybe
three four to six thousand people
uh lined up on each side once was not
enough they had to do it over and over
and over they didn't have microphones
and all the people wanted to hear at
every juncture during these proceedings
the people would take votes was that the
resignation sufficient maybe he should
change it this amazing amazing
outpouring by the end of it you have the
no zero british presence in the
massachusetts country pride 1774 eight
months before
what happens eight months later the
british tried to reconquer a land they
had already lost and that is the
counter-revolution which for all these
years has masqueraded as the revolution
to beginning the revolution phenomenal
discovery it's like the emperor's new
clothes why don't people see that
because we're locked into certain myths
we get those myths by too narrow a focus
if you just look at what the farmers
were doing during that time you see
what's happening
go on and on like this
all these people are seeking freedom the
slaves the uh the farmers the indians
they're all seeking their own version of
freedom it's not just the taxation
without representation people
um
a lot of the loyalists were seeking
their freedom you have in maryland
delaware hudson valley new york southern
back country you have loyalists who are
rebelling
against the elite the patriot elite the
the elite were patriots in those areas
these people become loyalists and they
fight for the loyalists for their
freedom lower class tenant farmers
so
pacifists
they're fighting for their freedom a
whole different way one in 30 free
americans during the revolutionary time
belonged to a religious pacifistic
organization which opposed all war in
this one in particular
uh they had to face the power of a very
oppressive government which which was
going at them they wanted their money
they wanted their bodies and they wanted
them to take oaths these people wouldn't
do it a lot of them landed in jail
so there's a whole story in that
um women
we uh a lot of us know that women gave
up tea and and fancy ornaments for the
sake of the revolution well some women
gave up fancy teeth i mean fancy
ornaments and tea those who could afford
it t was an upper class thing at that
time a lot of other women behaved quite
differently you had the lower class
women many of them joined the
continental army basically they had
nowhere else to go these were basically
homeless people and they became camp
followers other women are rioted for
against war profiteers for lower prices
you have a whole other level of
involvement here when you look at the
revolution from the standpoint of class
too you find out that
that it was really in 1775 there was a
massive outpouring of all classes
virtually all classes except at the very
top
of people against the british
by the
by the end of that year most people with
any form of property whether that was a
shop or a farm they went home to tend to
that property there was nobody left
except poor people they had to resort to
a draft
so in this draft if you you could simply
if you didn't want to go you'd be
drafted your number was called you
simply pay 20 bucks you get a substitute
it's an easy way out if you have the
money so by the end of the war you have
an absolutely
uh an army which is absolutely class
class driven lower class only except of
course for the officers and
impressionable young boys that's who won
the revolutionary war this is all all by
class now these are amazing
this is not the simple story this is not
the kind of the the one-dimensional
morality tale that we're raised with and
we're getting all this just but all we
have to do is look at the common people
and all this just emerges we can we can
we can we find all this these are not
really that controversial if you just
look there so why aren't we looking
there that's the big question i want to
address now what what are the
impediments to looking at people's
history why why don't we do it
um first of all there's the need for to
mythologize i mean all cultures have
have to create some kind of sort of
founding mythology why they came to be
who they are and implicitly that's
justification of who they are so we've
done that we've created our our founding
myth and in that myth we have our heroes
and these heroes
are kind of embody all the things that
we supposedly want all the virtues and
the values
that we aspire to
then added to this we have the natural
human inclination uh to identify with
somebody so history kind of calls out
for protagonist it needs that one
individual the the single person who
embodies the attributes of the many so
we have george washington is courageous
meanwhile there's ten thousand other men
who are waking up
about to go into battle and having to
face that battle knowing they might die
and what do we learn we learned george
washington is courageous it's kind of a
shorthand for the other people and then
the other people you know drift drift
you know through history just kind of
got left out of that of that telling
through this process we have washington
marched against cornwallis at yorktown i
love that one washington march because
washington didn't march
washington rode a horse
actually he walked i think according to
groucho marx he wrote a white horse
i learned that because that was the only
question i could answer
at the end of his show what was the
color of george washington's white horse
so
he did make things easy because i was
kind of young
at that time there was also one about
grant's tomb but anyway
um
where was i oh yeah
so washington is marching in this kind
of grand single combat against
cornwallis
this this kind of like leader down
this top down it's really it's trickle
downs you know trickle-down economics
okay this is trickle-down history
uh the historians don't call it
trickle-down history they don't give you
that's not the official school of
historians we are this historians
because howard and i believe we come
from a school we're kind of the school
of people historians and they don't say
we're from the school of trickle-down
historians uh but they do say but that
but there's another related words called
dissemination and the way dissemination
works is a few people have these great
ideas these are great thinkers and
visionaries and wonderful people who
generally tend to be quite well off in a
lot of time to think about these things
and and they they envision something and
then it happens so um you know
so you have like
the in the revolutionary period these
great men conceptualize the revolution
and others
uh follow they just fall until fall into
line
okay uh you have a few men kind of like
writing the play and the rest are just
delivering the script
these these top people they're called
leaders
think of what that means uh your leaders
leaders what does that mean you see even
even out here on the on your protest
you'll probably be like you know uh
rebel leaders or whatever you know spoke
you know leaders okay so now if they're
leaders who's everybody else
is a follower right i mean that's the
only way you know in a multiple choice
test leaders opposite followers choose
number a and you're right
okay so you have leaders and followers
what does that do that means these
people are just like following along
it's a way of belittling their very real
concerns
so if you're against any kind of social
movement you have a great vested
interest in calling people leaders this
is the way it works is the way and this
is the way we this kind of in the in the
sort of
uh underlying grammar of the way most
history is told from the standpoint of
leaders by the way i have a very sad
tale to tell about this
uh which is my first review my first
review was kirkus review and it said
started out uh people's history of the
american revolution how common people
shape the fight for independence this is
the story of slaves women rebel leaders
etc
what do i have to do to get through my
very first review rebel leaders you know
this is not the story of rebel leaders
by the way uh it's not my intent
okay uh these great people
there's a the whole
concept of how history works it's not
you know there's much more dynamic uh
flow between so-called leaders and
followers it doesn't work from the top
down just like that let me give you an
example thomas jefferson's declaration
of independence one of the great
documents of our time right conceived by
a mighty genius thomas jefferson well
it's a great document yes and it says
many great things so were this so were
several other documents which preceded
it on a local level which had many of
the same words which were made by little
county committees and conventions and so
on uh which drafted these things and
jefferson had at his disposal and he
made it he did a marvelous job of
synthesizing all these lesser-known
works and coming up with a document that
then he is then credited with and that's
kind of a good model for the way that
the kind of the process of leaders and
followers you actually have a
groundswell of support doing a lot of
the work one person kind of putting it
together in some way and then getting
all the credit is kind of like you know
just uh spun out of his mind and in some
kind of sort of immaculate conception
sort of way
okay
um so anyway we're facing this this is
what we're faced with all these sorts of
things
now
in people's history we also um
a lot of this is by the way consciously
manipulated uh
to to create
to lead away from the people to create
these special people on top let me read
you a little section here
this is a direct quote from charles
thompson
he's the secretary of the congress
i could not tell the continental
congress that is i could not tell the
truth without giving great offense
let the world admire our patriots and
heroes their supposed talents and
virtues where they were so by commanding
imitation will serve the cause of
patriotism in our country
okay so he's very consciously creating
this this kind of image of heroes and he
doesn't want to burst the bubble and so
of course at the end of his life he
actually burns his papers so we do not
have you know what whatever it was
inside that bubble you know we don't
know what it was
but we do get that idea a lot of this
stuff if we just take a self-conscious
approach to try to overcome it we can
for instance this marching washington
marched business uh in in people's
history
i have um
i tell the military story the war i tell
i give a narrative this actually is a
narrative history it's not kind of a
haranguing history you know arguing
points there's a narrative it tells
stories a myriad of stories as a matter
of fact if you look at the index here
and you see all the people in there
you're not going to recognize anything
these are all stories about common
people but it is storytelling so when i
come to the military history i tell the
story through five common soldiers who
were at
at the various battles and that's the
way that's the way i weave the tail
okay
so um so it can't it can be done but you
have to be very conscious about it even
so here's the biggest problem we face uh
which is more than just a problem of
attitude it's at a very concrete
physical problem that has to be
addressed and that's the problem with
sources where do you get sources for
slaves for indians for tenant farmers
who don't write so on a lot of common
people particularly as we go back in
time they didn't write even if they did
write could write they don't have quite
have the the leisure or the kind of
venue in which to write their their
letters aren't going to be preserved
in
insecure family structures nice
libraries passed on generation to
generation
so you have to overcome that
how do you do it
first of all
you do you look for what is there and
sometimes you get a little lucky out of
out of
half a million slaves
in the united states at that time there
were two complete narratives i mean by
complete i mean only 20 pages long or
something about their experiences during
that time these were people who did flee
to the british they were preachers so
they they basically wrote their memoirs
in religious journals that were
published during that time so we're
lucky we do have those two stories then
you have a few pension applications
later on
but
then oh here's another one uh an
iroquois warrior named black snake this
is really one of my favorites
he wrote a
he didn't know how to write but a friend
of his learned a little english and so
he knew how to read so black snake
dictated to his friend his memoir and
it's just fascinating stuff i include a
bunch of it in here incredible stories
uh such as
we get an inside look about when the
british are trying to basically convince
the iroquois warriors to join their side
and you get and he narrates the entire
argument the debate within circles
between the hawks and the doves
and then he also talks about what it's
like to be to be part of a slaughter
what it likes to be on a massacre kind
of both ends incredible documents so you
do get some of this some one one great
uh memoir which is published i include
some of it in the book but a fuller
version is that the shoemaker george
robert 12 hughes which is a book that
you several of you might be familiar
with
then you have
a few a few soldiers did leave letters
and and went and later memoirs
the things that you learned from the
from these
first-hand pieces let me read you one
because this this is um
really in a nutshell
shows you how much you can learn from a
very personal document this is actually
a pencil pension application this guy is
applying for a pension after the war
what's beautiful about this is you
didn't have to know how to write they
would this was oral history they would
actually if you were applying for a
pension you would go and they would take
down your story so a lot of time it says
deponent says this the opponent says
that it's really a first person kind of
thing
here we have this guy is in the south
and uh this is a story he tells his name
is moses hall
the evening after our battle with the
tories we having a considerable number
of prisoners i recollect a scene which
made a lasting impression upon my mind i
was invited by some of my comrades to go
and see some of the prisoners
we went to where six were standing
together some discussion taking place i
heard some of our men cry out remember
buford this was a site where the tories
massacred the
the patriot prisoners
and the prisoners were immediately hewed
to pieces with broadswords in revenge
for buford
at first i bore the scene without any
emotion but upon a moment's reflection i
felt such horror as i never did before
and or have since and returning to my
quarters and throwing myself upon my
blanket i contemplated the cruelties of
war until overcome and unmanned by a
distressing gloom from which i was not
relieved until commencing our march next
morning before day by moonlight
so he's he's uh he's sensitive to the to
the tragedies of war but later the next
day
being on the left side of the road as we
marched along i discovered lying upon
the ground something with appearance of
a man
upon approaching him he proved to be a
youth about 16 who having come out to
view the british through curiosity for
fear he might give information to our
troops they had run him through with a
bayonet and left him for dead
though able to speak he was mortally
wounded
the sight of this unoffending boy
butchered
relieved me of my distressful feeling
for the slaughter of the tories and i
desired nothing so much as the
opportunity of participating in their
destruction
so you have this very sensitive guy who
doesn't want to do this and that's this
kind of uh he gets he gets into it this
is this in a nutshell is war this kind
of strange twisted logic of revenge
so a lot of these uh when you can find
the sources take them and basically in
the people's history i've combed far and
wide for every available direct source
and it's in there uh in part and fully
referenced for you to find the rest
okay
beyond that though um you have to you
have to be more creative i use a trick i
call reflected images
we have the the documents of the elite
multi volumes of them they're still they
still don't have washington's all
completed they've been working on it for
decades now this is the new version of
washington's
um
so what
um
by looking at these things you can get
glimpses of how of of of the
of the life for the common people
for instance
1777 july 4th this is the first
anniversary of the declaration of
independence
washington's general orders no women
shall ride in the wagons
what's he talking about
what's he talking about is the women
camp followers are riding in the wagons
he doesn't like that because he wants
the wagons to be for men so they'll save
their energy
a month later absolutely no women ride
in the wagons
two months later if any women ride in
the wagon the men will be punished and
so on they'll be dismissed from the
truth he goes on he keeps escalating the
punishment this goes on for four years
uh and
until we find out from the one
one uh
direct source from a camp follower at
yorktown that she arrived at worktown
riding in a wagon
so what do we learn we learned that the
women rode in the wagons we learned that
the the men appreciated what they were
doing they had a you know they were into
it we learned that the men disobeyed
orders whenever they wanted pretty much
so we learn all sorts of things
from these indirect indirect sources
reflect reflected images i call them
one of the most incredible reflected
images really comes from
runaway slave ads
as i said they're very few direct
statements from slaves but consider this
as i read this try to figure out what
you can surmise by the slave owner the
slave in question and the nature of
slavery all of this is very there's a
lot to be said
this is happening this runaway slave ad
appears really right when lord dunmore
is issuing the british governor of
virginia is issuing his proclamation
freeing the slaves if they run to the
british
absented himself from the subscriber the
fourth of this instant a negro man named
limas he is of yellow complexion and has
the ends of three of his fingers cut off
his left hand he is well known in
charleston from his saucy and impudent
tongue of which i had had many
complaints
therefore i hereby give free liberty and
will also be much obliged to any person
to flog him so as not to take his life
in such manner as they shall think
proper whenever he is found out of my
habitation without a ticket
for though he is my property he has the
audacity to tell me he will be free that
he will serve no man and that he will be
conquered or governed by no man i've
forewarned masters of vessels from
carrying them off the province
so i mean that's a whole textbook in the
nature of slavery right there
sometimes we don't even have that to go
on we don't even have reflected images
okay but we can still make statements
let's continue with the slavery thing by
the way i'm focusing maybe more on
slavery now but i also deal with uh with
a full range i have
slavery all the native american groups
east of the mississippi are covered in
here with complete narratives loyalists
pacifists women of all classes the boys
who did the fighting and so on
but i'm focusing on slavery here
these people did run to the british okay
we know that
what we don't know is how they made that
decision
but about a fifth of them did four fists
did not it was a very dangerous task i
mean a lot of them died
as a matter of fact about as many people
died trying to find their freedom in the
british as white soldiers died in the
war
they died from being caught or they died
from disease so that another unknown and
huge
fact
but they have to make a decision are
they going to go or are they not going
to go
so how are they going to do this maybe
they're going to call a meeting like
this okay all the slaves on washington's
plantation at five o'clock uh let's get
together and we're gonna decide we're
gonna have a rally
yeah it doesn't work like that there's
slave informers everywhere this is
dangerous business we're talking about
undercover clandestine operations so we
know it has to have been because there
were slaves that were turned in they
have to have done it this way so they're
having these meetings they have to be in
small groups they're making these these
these uh decisions shall we run shall we
not so they're evaluating if we run
what's going to happen if we get caught
what's going to happen once we get there
if we don't run what happens if the
british then conquer the plantation
we're going to be sold into slavery go
to the west indies they're trying to
figure all this out they're trying to
weigh the dangers and the prospects
they have to be doing this we don't we
have no records of the journals okay but
we know they have to be doing it so i
include that in the story it has to be i
call this situational reconstruction i
don't by the way call that in this book
that's a fancy word for harvard but
situational reconstruction uh in the
book i just talk about the kind of
deliberations that they must be making
because all i'm doing is i'm putting
myself in their position and trying to
evaluate their hypothetical uh prospects
now this is a there's a movement in
history which does exactly this if you
look into what's being done in say
diplomatic history now you'll see people
say you can't just look at history as a
train leading up to the present you know
everything has a neat conclusion to you
know cause and effect to something else
that's that's that's too uh
one-dimensional and history doesn't work
like that at every point there's choices
and that's what history is about is
those choices and why they make those
choices so to make those choices you
have to go back to the times and try to
evaluate the prospects and that's how
you really get to learn about how the
people are experiencing those times this
is done in in all you know sort of
political history what i'm suggesting is
we take this kind of sophisticated and
very very obvious approach
all the way down to common people to the
full version when we do this we find all
the people are making all the people
throughout the revolutionary era making
very willed and conscious uh choices
about how to participate in political
action you have andrew gearing a a
pacifist
he's in jail because he won't take the
oath his minister is telling him he's
saying you're great andrew because
you're really true to your beliefs so
stay in jail and his wife is telling him
it's august the crops are in if you
don't get do whatever you have to do to
get out of jail we starve you know he's
making a decision he's trying to figure
that out you have joseph plum martin one
of my five principal soldiers here
talking in very moving terms about his
decision shall he join the mutiny or not
he's patriotic he believes in his cause
he's suffered all this time and he and
yet all the people are so he doesn't
want to go against his army against his
leaders but they haven't been paid and
they're starving does he mutiny or not
you have corn planter the corn planter
the iroquois warrior he captures his own
father because his father is an irishman
as it turns out john o'bail and he
captured what i mean what's he going to
do with his own father when he captures
him on the other side you have another
iroquois captures his brother who's also
fighting on the other side this is
really a civil war this is happening all
over the place what are these people
going to do
how are they how are they going to deal
with these kinds of uh decisions you
have this is a very moving one several
cases you have questions of soldiers
the whites and also some indian soldiers
coming acro across an unarmed man
you know and he's got the beat on him
he's pointing the rifle and he has to
decide whether to shoot the trigger pull
the trigger on a guy who he knows is
going to die
you know that direct and these guys for
years later they're this is haunting
them okay this is a view of war
this isn't the view of war that we get
you know when we just kind of read the
revolution it's not the rah-rah view
these people are making choices they are
political actors uh and there's their
actions are the revolution there's some
total of actions to get the full story
that's what we have to do we have to
study how all these people are
navigating the troubled waters of
revolution seeking their own freedoms in
their own multivarious ways okay when we
do this what we do is we go beyond the
simplistic morality tale which is the
usual revolution good and bad and of
course we're the good
and we go and we arrive at a much much
more complex and intriguing and really
humanly
full picture something we can really
identify with much more indicative of
the true diversity that we're seeking
today in our for our nation's identity
and also as individuals
so this is it um this is a people's
history
and i've done what i could do uh
people's history i think you know i'm
just to show you the book i think
because
you know uh i'm actually i'm kind of
proud of it i think the new press is has
done a great job with this book
and i'm totally thrilled to be involved
with howard on the project
and if you're into this thing this
people's history okay you have partly
howard to thank and also mark favreau
who's uh where's mark is he around here
stand up mark wherever you are where are
you are you here
come on stand up give it to
mark is my editor at newprez all the way
up mark i have a reason for this come on
all the way okay
so i want you guys to recognize mark and
the and this and here's my here's the
reason in my madness here because he's
kind of embarrassed because he didn't
know i was going to do this my reason is
is this is a people's history series and
and we're really into input as to what
that series could be what you know
further books for their ideas for the
whole the whole business so uh it's an
open-ended thing howard's working on the
series with mark and i'm just kind of
like hanging out and giving my two cents
so other people who have you know two
cents to give feel free we hope this
series is going to
really help to to push the study of
history forward
[Applause]
and uh
i think what's happening now maybe some
people are probably need to leave if you
do do uh but we're gonna stay for about
15 more minutes and howard and i would
love to have questions and engage in
some dialogue
so do we have
do we have people waiting at a mic here
okay
okay um what i'd like to know is how are
you gonna get this stuff into the
schools
uh thank you very much um are you a
plant did i tell you to say that no i'm
a mother with kids in school excellent
even better okay boston public schools
that's right good
excellent question this
this really is intended uh for use in in
that direction um
a couple of steps first of all
i did prepare a teacher's guide to this
questions from all the way from the kind
of simple comprehension questions to
very complex critical thinking questions
involving the footnotes i mean i have a
thousand footnotes in here
referencing all the original sources and
pointing people in those directions and
even inviting people to challenge my
statements and so on so we have that and
that will be available shortly um and
then we're also going to work on you
know there's a question of how these
things are going to sort of get by the
local school boards which are written
you know the standards seem to be
written more for a traditional form of
history
so i'm going to try to prepare and uh
working with the national standards a
sort of master little sheet which will
be available you know through with the
uh just request it and give me a couple
months for the thing to come out and
with the teachers edition
showing how this fits in with the
national standards
so you can and
actually have some ammunition to try to
get it into your schools
yeah
how do we work this
just let me add something to that um
i
i ran into this problem no one people's
history the united states came out the
problem was
you know how to get it into the schools
when the principal
and the
and the school board
and maybe the chair of the department
of the school won't like it
uh and one
thing that people did
is they simply
photocopied
parts
of the book
and uh and so long as we're free and
easy
mark favreau you won't mind
the new press no but really
very often that's the only thing you can
do
uh i mean where you can get it approved
officially
great you know and what happens is
there's a progression where people this
is what i found with the book at first
you know
surreptitious
photocopied chapters handed out to
students alongside the regular text and
then as you know the
it the idea began to seep
into the consciousness of the
educational uh world and become more
respectable then after a while yeah
adoptions and
and approvals and so on so
uh i mean i don't know how legal this is
but
but we don't care
let me say also about schools
this is written for a um
for just
an audience that any you know high
school or college or general trade
audience uh but hopefully it would be
available for lower um the stories in it
can be extracted this is a apropos
xeroxing so in other words a teacher
could take this and where the teachers
guide certainly develop all sorts of
lesson plans with this material
yeah
i was in binghamton new york recently
and in the newspaper i read a
controversy regarding an indian
holocaust memorial i wonder if you're
familiar with this apparently
george washington ordered the indians in
that region around binghamton
he ordered general sheridan i guess
to eradicate the indians men women and
children including their villages and
i
and i looked up a little bit about this
and apparently
this did happen washington gave the
order and the indians really were many
of them killed and the rest were moved
to uh or moved themselves to niagara
i wondered if
i never heard this before and i was
amazed it appears to be true are you
familiar with this if it's true
why haven't we heard about this in
history before there was a major major
campaign um against the iroquois
and by general sullivan and actually a
lot of his a lot of his
officers kept journals and the journals
were fascinating because they were like
the body counts you know for the vietnam
war oh yeah oh yeah direct order and
except they were vegetable counts
because this was this
the idea was to starve them so the
orders were to burn every piece of
everything that was growing it was a
certain you know it was a defoliation
early version of defoliation so they did
this they burned all the indian fields
uh throughout uh throughout new york and
of course the following winter was a
very hard one in great starvation and it
did absolutely zero to stop the indian
raids because what was the people who
would survive were the warriors and they
were furious so next year of course was
much worse along the frontier uh but
that's what it was it was it was really
a genocidal type of operation and you're
in right it's it's covered uh it's it's
covered in the book and then there are
references where you can actually go
back to the original sources written by
once once again reflected images because
the indians actually there's some of
this there is a captured india mary
jamison was captured when she was a
child and became she married an iroquois
warrior and she wrote something and she
wrote about the starvation that followed
and that's in here and then you can read
actually the accounts of the officers
themselves as well about this you get
the order from washington in his
what is it 1931 there's a 13 volume
biography you're probably familiar with
that if it's the other cereal there's
some gives it gives the order and you
you can look up general
whatever it is sullivan's journals too
and see his record yeah thank you yeah
yeah i just had a couple comments mainly
on uh dr zin's speech uh i mean i i
think
i i like the part you talked about how
the us has a history of
of class oppression and racism and
racial exploitation
a history just you know like harvard
also has a history of class exploitation
and class oppression and you also made
the connection which about what that you
have to use the study of history in
terms of what to do to get rid of this
so i just wanted to address what i think
needs to be done about to get rid of
class exploitation to get rid of class
oppression and
i'm a marxist i'm a follower of the
spartacus league we put out the paper
workers vanguard and we think that in
order to get rid of racism get rid of
racial oppression there has to be
if you will the history of a bottom
making of the history through the bottom
up in the same way the bolsheviks made
history in the bottom up which is to put
the working class in power through a
third american revolution just like the
civil war uh smashed slavery we think
there needs to be a revolution to smash
uh class slavery smash wage slavery and
so i just wanted to encourage everybody
to check out our paper workers vanguard
and also to read marx which i think
explains history of capitalism
howard do you want to comment
i don't think i need to comment
uh because it's not really a question
right it's a it's a manifesto
which you know
uh
do we need revolutions from below yes
absolutely
uh
but you know that's a what kind of
revolutions how when well i
you know that's very complicated
um
but
anyway it's uh
you know a welcome point of view
hi
thanks a lot for your comments um
one of the things i think is that most
of our traditional histories tend to
skew heavily towards elite driven
histories as you both discussed today
and the revolution's certainly a great
example of that and some of those
reasons for it are contemporary and some
of them are interposed and uh david
hackett fisher in paul revere's ride
gives us a good account of how the
lexington alarm which had
dozens and dozens and dozens of artisans
involved with became transposed by
longfellow because of civil war
propaganda into a single rider a lone
voice in the night
some of the reasons why we have an elite
history of the revolution i think
were contemporaneous with the revolution
itself
and i was wondering if you might want to
comment on what were some of those
reasons
for burnishing the elites
what was the perception
of the elites at the time and
reasons for
if you look at adams and jefferson
they're self-conscious of their place in
history and in most of the
quote founding fathers writings
they're speaking to posterity
what do you see as being some of the
reasons for their own
skewing history in favor of well they
had a very
difficult job because they wanted
something that was called a revolution
but obviously they didn't want
revolution
so you know they had a hard it's hard
balancing act
and they wanted to basically ally
themselves with people who did want a
revolution
and then quickly distance themselves
from that same
from those same people
and uh you know it's a complex way in
which we did in which they did this
and um
that's all i can say uh they sort of
managed to pull it off
which was uh
that's i guess it's to their credit but
uh but it was it was you know after the
revolution there was an attempt at
another revolution let me just uh
speaking of shae's rebellion which which
howard mentioned remember i mentioned
the 1774 revolution which was the
revolution was the real overthrow of the
government throughout all of
massachusetts
that was in 1774 in 1786
exactly 12 years later to the day
actually one day less because like in
springfield it was august 30th and 12
years later was august 29th because the
way the courts were meeting the exact
same people showed up but not quite as
many of them and tried to do the exact
same thing they tried to engage in a
second revolution this is something in
terms of the history of shae's rebellion
it's just it's never fully understood
because people don't understand the
context that these guys were just trying
to do a repeat performance and the iron
you know the the the the result was the
first one succeeded and the second one
failed and that's sort of how you can
mark what happened uh after the
revolution that was the mark that uh
that the revolution was not going to the
second revolution the full social
revolution was not going to succeed
that there's a lot more to to speak
about that i'm glad you raised the issue
but you know i mean that's a huge issue
yeah let me just say one more thing
about that and that is that
there's this continuity
you know that ray is talking about you
know from 1774
1786 and of course before 1774 and after
1786 but in the midst of the revolution
in the midst of the war against england
which presumably is you know as
uh ray said you know the story is of
united colonists patriotic war and so on
but in the midst of that there are
mutinies
which are class based that is
the
soldiers the privates
are being
treated like dirt the officers are being
treated like kings and uh you know
they're getting uh
high pay and good clothes and good food
and they're having parties and so on and
and the and the pilots uh uh not giving
any clothes not getting any pay and
being kept in when they want to be
mustered out their time or services up
and so they mutiny in 1781 their number
in 1781 they're the mutiny of thousands
of soldiers in the pennsylvania line and
washington has to be very careful in
dealing with that because there are
thousands of them he's worried he
expresses this that this is this may
spread to the whole revolutionary army
and so he deals with them by
compromising but then shortly after that
there's another mutiny in the new jersey
line where only a few hundred mutineers
are involved at that point washington
gets tough
and you know there's this romanticized
picture of washington which uh well as
we see uh is dispelled when you look at
how he treats black people and how he
treats indians but also how he treats
presumably his own his own soldiers when
they when he feels he can handle the
mutiny in the new jersey line his orders
are
shoot them
and so they take out by random actually
it's almost like the movie paths of
glory where they you know pick out at
random you know the troublemakers at
random they pick them out and they have
them executed by their fellow mutineers
i think sometimes it's hard for
people whether historians or just
students in school to
pursue lines of thought that go against
what the mainstream is telling them is
the right thing to believe and what is
oftentimes the more easy thing to
believe in and i've read a couple of mr
zinn's books and i feel like i have a
somewhat of an idea about how that
process occurred in his life but i was
just curious about
when you
made the decision you mentioned earlier
i don't know jokingly or not about being
in a school of
people's historians how do you get to
that place you know it's not like
your education probably led you to that
early on
what makes you
follow that path uh i'm going to give
you sort of an academic version and a
political and a uh um political activist
version the academic one is actually
when i first ran into in the uh
in um when i was in high school and i
ran into a one of these collections of
slave narratives you know from the wpa
projects and the the ba botkin laid my
burden down it was a collection of those
where the
writers went down and collected all the
narratives i could not believe i was
reading these you know firsthand
accounts from slaves i was so struck by
this i mean i don't know hit me deeply
the other one is an activist and really
got me into the the power of uh people's
history was howard's inn
and howard's in he doesn't know this i
was about to tell him this story uh this
afternoon and we ran out of time so i'm
telling to you now
yeah right i know because you've been
we've been waiting all this time right
that's uh that's why he's sitting there
he's still waiting i know right
so here's what happened i'm in the south
in 1964 working with snick i was just a
volunteer and um
and meanwhile and this is a this is a
big year you know it's where the people
are murdered and everything and there's
bombings and all this is going on and
then we're preparing for the mississippi
uh freedom democratic party to go to the
convention to challenge
so um anyway meanwhile what what's in
the press is usually still there's all
this stuff about martin luther king and
the established leadership and what i'm
seeing on the ground is this incredible
i mean these people who work with snick
i couldn't believe them i couldn't
believe them i was just awed i was like
floored i mean this was like i don't
know
to see their commitment and the dangers
they faced every day in their life force
and their vitality and then right then
howard zinn comes out with a book called
snick the new abolitionist
and it's amazing it gets the story
absolutely right and i had never i've
been in the movement for a while at this
time and every time you're in the movie
you go to a demonstration then you read
about it in the paper the next day you
know what that wasn't the demonstration
i was at and here there's a political
event and i'm seeing and he's writing
about it from the bottom up and this was
before that that term bottom up had even
been coined and he's doing it and that
really impacted me that that could be
done
uh you know so indirectly most people
here are kind of affected by it by the
people's history and you know i guess we
shared enough in common that we go that
far back so thank you
[Applause]
so howard has no johnny come lately to
this movement
yeah
i was fascinated by what you were saying
about the indians and enslaved blacks
running to the british army
could you speculate um whether they
would have been better off um
if the the british you know had in fact
prevailed
if the british had prevailed
once they ran to the army they didn't uh
really at the there's two stages the
early part of the war where they were
actually technically offered their
freedom and a few received it uh but not
that many and then later in the war
where they went by the droves that's
where the tens of thousands went and and
at this time that it was just sort of an
implicit thing maybe you'll get free and
they weren't basically what happened
they would become servants of officers
they would be placed in very hard labor
situations some of them would actually
be taken off as slaves by uh by
loyalists um so very few really uh out
of out of may approximately 80 000
slaves that ran to the british for their
freedom
3 000 exactly received their freedom and
i'd say that is the number of slaves
that were
recorded as as as being taken to canada
um you know for the you know as as free
slaves after the war now um it's hard to
say what would have happened what did
happen is the revolution for the
institution of slavery
tended to rigidify that institution
because before the revolution the
institution of slavery hadn't really
been challenged and this did challenge
it and that caused the slave owners to
create a kind of reaction
and so a lot of the tale of the
revolution for slaves is increasing
reaction at home
momentary kind of freedom some of these
people actually there were maroon
communities where they actually were
free for a while so there was kind of a
momentary taste of freedom and then
after war
clamped down totally that's where you
get the rigidified slave codes they came
right in the wake of the revolution
um i really am i'm enjoying uh this
session and particularly with the
questions that came out because that
made concrete some of the implications
for doing a new social history with the
looking at it more in a more
comprehensive holistic way
one of the things uh that i wonder and
i'm going to get your book to see it
to what extent can we spell out make
obvious
how our understanding of where we are
today
is changed and different because of what
we now know
about what happened then
no know listen
we know that it was complicated
there were many different groups with
different particular perspectives and
issues
it wasn't organized and
integrated as as it seems in retrospect
the future always looks uncertain the
past looks like it's inevitable so the
question is
when when we do these kinds of histories
is it clear that we try to spell out
how
our understanding is now different
and
more adequate to the outcome that we saw
in the more limited industries from top
down
in your book you tried to show how our
understanding
about the american revolution is either
uh
deepened
or in some way changed
number one number two are there lessons
when we look at that at this period are
the lessons we can draw from today okay
just as we stated yeah well remember i
said at the beginning that when we learn
history is how we learn the grammar of
the political process you know it's how
we learn to interpret the political
process so when and i use that in a
negative way because when we learn the
elite history that's what we're learning
so you can just take the converse of
that to answer your question if you
learn the history if the if you're
growing up you learn that people are
proactive that people gather together
that in a real in what democracy means
is not voting it's a lot more than
voting it's people gathering together
for their own
interests and standing up for their
interests and so on you take that kind
of image of that's you know that grammar
and translate it to the present
presumably you will make that a much
more
uh normal or accepted or integral part
of contemporary society these things
aren't and it's no accident really that
this kind of history is coming out today
i mean this history really is in a sense
coming it's flowing directly from the
1960s uh the the historians that that
are really i mean a lot of this is based
on on you know historical research which
has come directly out of the uh the
1960s uh by a great wave of new social
history
i had an opportunity to learn about
american
economic and social history
and i use lowell as an example i learned
from my colleagues we taught a course in
an interdisciplinary fashion i
understood much more deeply how the
feminist movement over the course of our
history developed the unintended
consequence of the industrial revolution
getting cheap farm girls to come in
was in the course of the of learning
disciplined work and organization being
educated by people like thoreau in order
to please their father they had a
special educational program
and then
when
there was a cutback
in work because
the the merchant princes who couldn't
sell
apply the trade to
china
had an opportunity to invest in
developing
textile industries over built
they cut their way to these women the
women
then organized as many of us know
and it shows how the nature of life
itself as both and predicted by karl
marx
the actual experience of organization
transforms people
and developed
leadership for the next several
generations women who were active in the
feminist movement and in the
abolitionist movement and the like so i
think there's a lot of important uh
observations we can make in lessons
for tonight
right and the message is that if we do
this with any particular period or
subject in history if you take that
attitude you're going to wind up with
that kind of impact on contemporary
consciousness thank you right
right yeah we're told we have three more
questions these three people so
we we are told that anonymous right
yeah um
i just like to commend you both because
not only does your work bring more
perspective
but it brings passion to education
so thank you thank you
a reminder that you can use c-span video
in your classroom for lessons on u.s
government and history